I used to carry mace I don't carry mace
anymore cuz I find the packaging way too
patronizing when you try to buy Mason's
a woman they try to sell you mace in a
pink bottle I'm trying to look scary I'm
trying to look menacing don't give me
something that looks like a toy Atta
Dora the Explorer's backpack
or the vibe I'm going for a lot of my
girlfriend's talk about how when they
walk to their car they put a key in
between their fingers yeah but they
don't even make metal car keys anymore
okay the new car keys are those little
plastic little remotes so that's a
conspiracy think about that shit for a
minute the one weapon we have has been
taken from us so now I gotta use my
mailbox key like an asshole
little shitty Wolverine could you come
forward a fucking inch shitty Wolverine
and it's just kind of tickling my
attacker at this point kind of
delicately caressing him it's kind of
bringing him to climax at this place you
look like a villain in an 80s movie it's
just that way